The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHELE: Welcome
to lecture three
on quantum mechanical methods.
As you may have
guessed, I'm not Jeff,
as much as I look
like him, I know.
I'm actually a graduate
student of his.
I'm Michele.
So feel free to interrupt
me with any questions you
have during this.
And this is a really exciting
class today because today,
we're actually going to
start talking about some
of the quantum methods
that we've been doing
in the background up till now.
So first of all, I
guess you guys know
that you don't have
class on Thursday,
but I guess for those
of you doing projects,
you can go meet with
Professor Buehler then.
So on our outline, we are here.
We're going to be talking a
little bit about modeling,
the beginnings of
modeling today,
and a little bit
about molecules.
So last time, we talked about
a single electron system.
We talked about hydrogen, and
actually, that gave us a lot.
We were able to explain how
spectral lines came about, just
from understanding the
basic structure of hydrogen.
But today, we're going to
work on more-than-one electron
systems.
And you'll see that this is
where the computation really
becomes necessary.
So here's the outline.
So you can see
today, we're going
to talk a little bit about
Hartree and Hartree-Fock
methods, and density
functional theory.
So I believe you
guys are going to be
using density functional theory
to your next problem set.
So just some review
from last time--
here's the Schrodinger
equation that I'm
sure you're all sick
of seeing by now.
In general, if our system
is time independent,
then our Hamiltonian is
going to be time independent.
And we can separate
the variables
into the spatial component
and the time component.
And then by dividing
out the time component,
we are left with this
stationary, time-independent
Schrodinger equation.
And that's the equation
that we've been solving
and we will continue to solve.
So as I said, last time we
talked about the hydrogen atom.
We just solved its Hamiltonian.
The Hamiltonian itself is,
of course, the kinetic energy
and the potential energy.
The kinetic energy is this.
The potential energy is actually
just that Coulomb attraction
between the electron and the
proton in that hydrogen atom.
And this, we saw, was
pretty simple to solve.
I guess we didn't actually do
it, but the way this is solved
is you switch into
spherical coordinates.
You solve for a radial
component of the wave function,
and an angular component
of the wave function.
So to any of you who have
had a lot of chemistry,
these probably
look very familiar.
So this is the s, these three
are p, these five are d.
And these are basically
just the spherical harmonics
that you get from
solving the theta and phi
parts of the Hamiltonian.
And when we combine these,
we get the total spatial wave
function for the hydrogen atom.
So the spatial wave
function is described
by these quantum numbers.
And the principle quantum
number, l, the angular momentum
component, and m l, which is
the angular momentum component,
projected along the z axis.
So you guys have probably
seen these a million times--
that leads to these
spatial wave functions.
So this is increasing
principal quantum number
and this is increasing
angular momentum.
All right, so we've all
seen this graph now a couple
of times.
Can somebody tell me what
this graph represents?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELE: Right.
And why is it important that
there are these specific lines
that it can go between?
I mean, what phenomenon are
we capturing with this idea?
AUDIENCE: We can [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELE: Right.
So this is why people
observed spectral lines
instead of seeing a
continuous spectrum.
and so atoms, instead of
emitting a continuous spectrum,
emit specific lines.
And that puzzle was solved by--
we actually already solved it
last time with the solution
to the hydrogen atom, because we
saw that the hydrogen atom had
these discrete energy levels.
And electrons could only
exist in those specific energy
levels.
And so when an electron went
between those two energy
levels, it would emit the
energy of that difference
in energy levels as a photon.
And that photon would
be a specific wavelength
corresponding to
a specific color,
and that's exactly
where this emission line
spectrum comes from.
So let's try to add
one more electron.
So this is our Hamiltonian
now for helium.
We still have the kinetic part,
the T for electrons 1 and 2.
We have the potential part
for electrons 1 and 2.
That's the interaction of
the electrons with the helium
nucleus.
But now we have this term
that's the Coulomb repulsion.
It's the two electrons
interacting with each other.
And this makes the
problem suddenly
unable to be solved
analytically,
just this addition
of one more electron.
I guess you could think of it as
sort of the three-body problem
in classical mechanics.
So last time, we also
talked about spin.
So we know that electrons are
either spin up or spin down.
Does anybody remember
the experiment
that was done to show this?
AUDIENCE: Stern-Gerlach.
MICHELE: Yeah, good job.
So the Stern-Gerlach
experiment, basically it
was a stream of
electrons that were
shot through this magnetic
field and then were
observed on a plate behind it.
So electrons being shot
through this magnetic field
is kind of like the spin
component of the wave function
being observed.
So now that we're observing
this wave function,
it can only be in
its eigenstates.
So those eigenstates
are here and here.
So you think if you
have an electron that
can interact with
a magnetic field,
its magnetic moment could be
pointing sort of any direction.
So if it's pointing
perpendicular
to the magnetic
field, why would you
expect there to be any
kind of interaction?
You just expect it to end
up in the middle here.
And similarly, it could be
anywhere between up or down.
But this is quantum mechanics.
This magnetic field is
making a measurement.
And so we all know that
once a measurement is
made in quantum mechanics,
the wave function
collapses to one of its
observable eigenstates.
So it may seem strange to you
that if you know something
about where magnetic moments
usually come from, usually
we talk about magnetic fields
being produced by electrons
physically spinning in space.
But this is just some
property of an electron
that creates a magnetic moment,
without any kind of movement.
So that's still something
that we don't really
understand today, what
exactly that spin means.
But we observe it and
it seems necessary,
so right now, all we can say is
that we know electrons either
spin up or they're spin down.
And Jeff showed you
last time this letter
to Pauli about
how even Pauli was
a little skeptical of
this spin quantum number,
but it's actually crucial
for his exclusion principle.
So does anybody remember the
Pauli exclusion principle?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELE: Exactly.
So all the electrons
have to have--
all four quantum
numbers have to be
different between any
pair of electrons.
So the four quantum
numbers, again,
are the three
spatial components,
and now we've added one
more, which is spin.
Pauli himself said, "Already
in my original paper
I stressed the
circumstance that I
was unable to give a logical
reason for the exclusion
principle or to deduce it
from more general assumptions.
I had always the feeling,
and I still have it today,
that this is a deficiency."
So Pauli came up with this.
He used it.
It explained the periodic
table, but he had no idea
why this had to be true.
And doesn't it bother you
guys that there's just
this arbitrary rule
that we're saying
no two electrons can have the
same four quantum numbers?
Well, today, we're actually
going to explain this.
We're going to explain
what Pauli could not.
So let's move on to
new stuff, unless there
are any questions so far.
OK, so today, we're
going to be talking
about what happens
when we have more
than one electron in a system.
So we could be
talking about helium
with two electrons,
iron, 26 electrons.
We'll move up to molecules,
solids, things with 100s,
1,000s of electrons.
Dirac said in 1929, "The
underlying physical laws
necessary for the
mathematical theory
of a large part of physics
and the whole of chemistry
are thus completely
known, and the difficulty
is only that the exact
application of these laws
leads to equations much too
complicated to be soluble."
So basically, he was
feeling pretty cocky here.
It's like we understand
the theory of everything.
We understand the
periodic table.
There's nothing left
to do in chemistry.
We understand now.
We can write the equations
for how all molecules work,
how all solids work.
And it's the complication of
these mathematical formulas
that turned out
to be the problem.
So many years later, he still
was struggling with these.
And he says, "If there's
no complete agreement
between the results of one's
work and the experiment,
one should not allow himself
to be too discouraged."
So even after all
this time struggling
to solve this equation,
he still could not
agree with experiment.
And even today, we still cannot
always agree with experiment,
but that's no reason not to try.
So this was our
basic Hamiltonian
that we had for just
the hydrogen system.
It was just the kinetic
and potential energy.
It's as simple as that.
Well, now our equation looks
a little bit more like this.
So I don't want you to be too
intimidated by this equation.
It seems to have a
lot of terms in it,
so let's go through
them for a simple case.
So let's say we'd
have the simplest
molecule you can think of, H2.
So let's say you have a
nucleus here, nucleus here,
and an electron that
originally was associated
with this one, and
another electron
originally associated with this.
So what are these terms
in the Hamiltonian?
So what do we need to consider?
So this first term here
is the kinetic energy
of the nuclei themselves.
So it's how this nucleus and
this nucleus are moving around.
So in this very
simple case, we'd
have two terms in this sum.
This next is the interaction
[? C-C ?] of Z i and a Z j.
So it's the interaction of
the nuclei with each other.
It's the Coulomb repulsion
of nucleus 1 and nucleus 2.
So in this case, that's
actually just one term.
This next term is the kinetic
energy of the electrons.
So it's, in this
case, two terms.
We have electron 1 and electron
2 that are zooming around,
and that's their kinetic energy.
The next term is
there's only one Z,
so it's the interaction of
the nucleus and the electrons.
So here, we have four
of those interactions.
We have electron 1 interacting
with nucleus 1 and 2,
electron 2 interacting
with nucleus 1 and 2.
And finally, we have electrons
interacting with themselves,
so the Coulomb
repulsion of electrons.
So in this case, again,
there's just one term
because there are
only two electrons.
So I think all of these
terms are labeled properly.
So our equation now has
become rather complicated.
Instead of just
having one coordinate,
which was the relative
coordinate between the nucleus
and the electron that we
had in the hydrogen case,
now we have this
Hamiltonian that
depends on the position
of all the nuclei
and the position of
all the electrons,
and our wave
function that depends
on the position of all the
nuclei and all the electrons.
So this has become a massively
complicated equation.
So at this point, what
are we going to do?
You might think to
yourself that you're stuck,
that this equation
is too complicated.
You'll never get anywhere.
And just as you're
despairing, this man walks in,
pulls down the
back of his shirt.
Might take you a little while
to stare at these equations,
because you'll recognize this as
being the equation we just had.
And he's giving you the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
So let's look at
this approximation,
maybe not on somebody's back.
So Born was a pretty
foundational guy
in quantum mechanics.
He did a lot of work
And I'm sure you all recognize
the name Oppenheimer.
So these two guys, what
they decided to do,
they looked at this picture,
and they thought about the fact
that a proton is 2,000 times
the mass of an electron.
And so because this
electron is so heavy,
it's just moving so
slowly with respect
to these electrons that
are zipping around.
And so basically, what
they decided to do
is just ignore that
motion of the nucleons.
So the nuclei are moving so
much slower than the electrons
that basically, you can assume
that the electrons will figure
out their ground state, figure
out where they need to be,
by the time any kind
of nucleus has moved
even a fraction of an Angstrom.
So because we're now
neglecting the kinetic energy
of the nucleons, we
can also just calculate
the ion-ion interaction
classically.
So that really simplifies
our Hamiltonian.
So now, we're just left
with these three terms.
So it's the kinetic
energy of the electrons
only, the interactions of the
electrons with the background
positive charge--
so where the ions are--
and the interaction of the
electrons with themselves.
So we're from now
on, we're mostly
going to call this term just
the "external potential," so
"external" because we
don't care about the motion
of these nuclei anymore.
So this leads us to
actually starting
to talk about how we do
these approximations.
So traditionally, there
have been two pathways
that have been followed.
There's what a lot of
quantum chemists have taken,
and we'll talk about that
first, but there's also
density functional theory, which
is what a lot of physicists
have traditionally used.
And I'm not going to talk about
either of these two in detail.
But I'll just mention, the
Moller-Plesset perturbation
theory is a perturbation
theory. so it's
based on changing
the Hamiltonian,
so assuming that the Hamiltonian
is pretty much something
we can solve, and
then just adding
a small correction to it.
And the coupled
cluster approach is
more of a traditional quantum
chemistry approach, where
instead of modifying
the Hamiltonian,
we just modify the
wave functions.
And we play around
with the wave functions
until they become something
that's more close to something
that would exist in reality.
So let's talk about the basis of
the quantum chemistry approach.
So this is Hartree.
He was working right
after World War
I. I think this was
actually his dissertation,
and he got his PhD for doing
this very important work.
So what he decided is
we have this system
that we want to solve.
We have a wave
function that's made up
of all of these electrons that
are zooming around in space.
Well, what if that kind
of acted like a bunch
of one-electron wave functions?
What if we could
just assume that we
could know where one electron
was, and another electron was,
and we just could just multiply
all those together to give us
the total wave function?
So all of a sudden, this really
complicated wave function
becomes something that's
pretty easy to separate.
So because we can
separate them like this,
we can separate them into a set
of-- so if we have electrons 1
through n, we'll have
a set of Schrodinger
equations 1 through n, for
each electron by itself.
So this is great.
We've separated our Hamiltonian.
We now can solve
the system, right?
So there is a problem here.
This is the density
of electron j.
We're doing a sum over j
from electron 1 through n,
and just skipping the
electron that we're
considering in this case.
So all of us is saying
this electron that we'd
like to solve depends
on the positions
of every single other
electron in that system.
So even in this most simplified
version of the Schrodinger
equation, we still
have the one electron
depending on all of
the other electrons.
So how do we solve
something like this?
Do you guys know?
I think this is even a little
more complicated than something
Mathematica can solve.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHELE: Pretty much.
Well-- what we do is we try
a self-consistent approach.
We basically just guess what
these wave functions look like.
We say, well in
this case, we know
that it's a sigma bond that's
forming between these two,
so probably the electron
is somewhere in here.
And so if I guess some
structure that looks something
like this is my wave
function, that's
maybe a good starting point.
And so we put input
that into this equation.
We take out the first
electron, and we're
going to now solve the
Schrodinger equation
for the first electron.
So we plug in what
we've guessed as being
the wave functions for all the
other electrons into this term.
And now we solve for
this one electron term,
for electron number 1.
And then we do that
again for electron 2,
and so on until we've gone
through all of the electrons.
And then when
we're done, we have
a new set of wave functions.
So maybe my guess was wrong
and it looks something more
like this.
And so we look at
that, and say, wow,
those two really don't look
anything like each other.
I need to try this again.
And so we go
through this process
over and over again
until finally,
the solutions to these wave
functions prior to doing this
and after going
through and solving
all of these eigenfunctions
look pretty much the same.
And once we've
done that, we know
that we've probably gotten
something at least relatively
close to the ground-state
solution, or the solution
that we're looking for.
So does that make
sense to you guys?
Are there any questions?
OK, because this is actually
pretty close to how DFT works,
too.
This is the
self-consistent method
that is pretty common in
solving these problems.
So this is great.
We have a way of doing this.
Given that we can come up
with some reasonable guess
for our input wave
functions, we now
can solve the Schrodinger
equation, right?
Yes and no.
This picture is nice
and simple and soluble,
but it takes out all
of the interactions
that you get, or
all of the effects
that you get from
interactions beyond just
that coulomb repulsion, of
electron-electron Coulomb
repulsion.
Because remember, this
is a quantum system.
These electrons
don't behave like you
expect they would in some kind
of classical Newtonian system.
These electrons are weird.
We'll see later on some of the
symmetries that we can look at.
Actually, I think that's next.
But these electrons--
you wouldn't
expect to just be able
to just average over all
of the effects.
Because this truly was a
multi-electron function.
We're missing some
critical physics here
by just separating it out
into single electron functions
and just multiplying
those back together.
So we're missing
two important terms.
They're going to be
called the "exchange"
and the "correlation" term.
And the fix to at least
part of this problem
brings us back to spin.
So as I said, in
quantum mechanics,
symmetry is really,
really important.
Symmetry tells us a lot
about the way nature works.
So even in classical
mechanics, you guys
have probably encountered
the symmetry of real space,
the symmetry of time,
things like that.
And that's what gives you the
conservation laws in mechanics.
So just like that's
true in mechanics,
it's also true in
quantum mechanics.
So we're going to be looking
at one particular symmetry,
and talking about how
that might give us
some insight into this problem.
So that symmetry is called
"exchange symmetry."
So that's based on the
fact that electrons
are indistinguishable.
So what does it mean to be
really indistinguishable?
So if I have, maybe, two
pieces of chalk that look--
I guess they're not
exactly the same,
but they look pretty similar.
And let's say I want to follow--
I'm going to call this one
Fred and this one George.
And I'm going to follow their
movement throughout space.
So if I give them
an initial position
and some initial velocity,
I know throughout all time
which one is Fred and
which one is George.
Because I knew their
exact initial position.
I knew their exact
initial velocity.
I can calculate
their trajectories.
I know which one is which.
But that's not
true for electrons.
So does anybody know the
uncertainty principle?
Can somebody tell me what
the uncertainty principle is?
Yeah.
Did you volunteer?
AUDIENCE: No, I didn't.
I [INAUDIBLE]
algebraic [INAUDIBLE]..
MICHELE: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHELE: Right, so the exact
mathematical formulation
is something like the
uncertainty in the momentum
times the uncertainty
in the position
has to be always greater
than or equal to basically
some constant.
So if I have my two
starting electrons,
and I have some idea
of where it starts,
and with some idea of what
velocity it starts with,
and some other electron-- with
similarly not an exact position
but some kind of position
and some kind of knowledge
of the velocity--
it's clear that over
time, I'm going to have
no idea which one was which.
They'll switch and I won't
be able to tell that they've
switched because I can't follow
their trajectories the same way
I can with classical objects.
And furthermore, electrons don't
have any identifying marks.
They don't have like a beauty
mark somewhere that can tell us
which one was the
electron that we really
fell in love with first.
And so electrons act
completely indistinguishable.
And so this is a symmetry
we're going to exploit.
So let's say we have a
system full of electrons,
and I pull a curtain
in front of you
so you can't see
the system anymore.
I take one electron, and
I take another electron,
and I swap them exactly.
I swap their positions,
I swap their momentum,
I swap everything about them.
And I open that
curtain again, you
won't be able to tell at all
that anything's happened,
because these electrons act
exactly like each other.
So it doesn't matter if I
swapped one with another.
So this might sound
a little bit dumb.
I mean, you might be
sitting there thinking,
OK, this is obvious.
Why is she going on so long
about something so obvious?
And the reason is
when we formalize
this in terms of
mathematics, suddenly
things become
really interesting.
So we're going to define
an exchange operator, which
is this chi 1 2.
So chi 1 2 acting
on a system that
has an electron 1 and electron
2, all it's going to do
is swap electron
1 with electron 2.
Just so this
formalism makes sense,
this 1 refers to what
particular wave function it is.
So this psi 1 refers to that
set of four quantum numbers,
or set of whatever quantum
numbers describes that system.
And similarly, psi 2
describes a different set
of quantum numbers, and r1 is
the position of electron 1, r2
is the position of electron 2.
So when we use this exchange
operator on our system,
we get something that
should be indistinguishable.
And you can see that
if we act twice--
so if we have electron 1
and 2, and we swap them,
and then we act again
with the exchange operator
and we swap 1 and 2,
we'll switch back.
So we know mathematically that
this exchange operator, acted
twice on a system,
leaves you exactly
with the original
system that you had.
So we have to assume
here that this wave
function is going to be an
eigenstate of the exchange
operator.
And there is a quantum
mechanical reason for that.
But what this tells us,
assuming that we've now
acted with this
exchange operator twice,
we know that the value of the
eigenvalue of the exchange
operator squared is
equal to 1, which
gives us that the
eigenvalue itself
has to be plus or minus 1.
So just to be clear,
what I've said
is that when I act
on this wave function
with this exchange operator--
so I have my total
wave function, whatever
it is, which is a function
of multiple electrons,
when I act with this
exchange operator on it,
I get something where
I've switched r1 and r2,
and all the other electrons
are left the same.
And what I said in
the previous slide
is that these two states--
this state and this state--
have to act exactly the same.
But now I've also
told you that this
is equal to some eigenfunction
times the original wave
function.
And this eigenfunction, I've
said, can be negative 1.
So can anybody
reconcile this for me?
How can this eigenfunction
be negative and yet
have this original
eigenstate not be changed,
or have no measurable
difference between the electrons
being in the original positions
or 1 and 2 being switched?
So the key to the question
is actually the term
"measurable difference."
So remember, Jeff has said
that in quantum mechanics,
we have this wave function.
We have no idea what the
wave function actually means.
It's the square, the absolute
value square of the function,
that actually is meaningful.
So you can see, even if
this is a negative 1,
and we have a negative 1 in
front of the wave function,
when we square that, the
negative is going to disappear.
So we still have this symmetry
because the thing that's
measurable is the absolute value
squared of the wave function,
and not the wave
function itself.
But this is actually a pretty
key piece of quantum mechanics.
So we have two possible
values for this wave function.
So this wave function
can be positive 1
or it can be negative 1.
So any quantum
mechanical system is
going to have a wave
function that either
has the eigenvalue for
this equation positive 1
or negative 1.
When it's positive 1,
we call them "bosons."
So this leads to a lot
of interesting physics,
like the Bose-Einstein
condensate,
which I don't know if you
guys have heard about.
There's a lot of
cool experiments
that have been done
on helium 4, where
at a low enough temperature,
all of the helium atoms
suddenly find themselves in
exactly the same ground state.
And there's some really
bizarre consequences of that.
However, what
we're interested in
are the particles with
an eigenvalue of minus 1.
Those are called "fermions."
Electrons are fermions.
So electrons,
therefore, need to have
an eigenvalue of negative 1.
And this is actually the key to
the Pauli exclusion principle.
So this is why the Pauli
exclusion principle is true.
So can somebody
explain to me that?
It's kind of a subtle point.
Does anybody see that?
So let's look at a
wave function that
doesn't follow the Pauli
exclusion principle
and see what happens.
So let's say I
have two electrons.
I'm going to put them both
in the 1s with spin up.
So what happens when I
operate with this exchange
operator on this?
So these two are
exactly the same.
So I needed a negative 1
here, but I have a positive 1.
So because this exchange
gives me the wrong sign,
I know anything that has
some system like this, where
I have the same quantum numbers
on two different particles,
has to be a boson
and not a fermion.
So let me just give you an
example of a wave function
that does satisfy the
proper eigenstate for this.
So if we have something
like 1 over root
2 1s up for particle 1,
1s down for particle 2,
minus 1s down for particle 1
times 1s up for particle 2.
So can everybody see?
If I switch 1 and 2, I'm going
to get the negative of this.
Because these two are going to
switch and become this term,
these two are going to
switch and become this term.
Is that clear?
I'm seeing a lot of blank faces.
I hope that means that
people are way past this
and have mastered this long ago.
Are there any questions on this?
To me, this is really exciting.
This is great to be able to
finally explain something
that Paul himself
couldn't explain.
We actually can understand
quantum mechanically
why electrons behave
the way they do,
why we have the Pauli
exclusion principle,
and therefore, why we
have the periodic table.
I mean, this is a
pretty big consequence.
[DOOR CLOSING]
I guess it was so big,
he couldn't take it.
All right, let's move on to
what the implication of this
is in the Hartree method.
So a guy named Fock
came along, and he
has either a very fortunate
or very unfortunate name,
depending on how
you feel about him.
And he basically just took an
anti-symmetrized wave function.
So anti-symmetrized just
means this characteristic,
that when you act upon
it with this operator,
you get a negative 1.
So he just put in an
anti-symmetrizied wave function
into Hartree's original
equation, which was just,
if you remember, just this.
It's the kinetic part
and then from the ions,
the potential part from
the other electrons.
So this was the
original equation.
And when he plugged in an
anti-symmetrized wave function,
suddenly, this term appeared.
So this is the term we
call the "exchange term."
If you look very
closely at it, you'll
see that what it does
is quantum mechanically,
two electrons with the
same spin will never
be in the same position.
And it basically subtracts
out that possibility,
of two electrons with the same
spin being in the same place.
So this actually reduces
the energy of the system
because suddenly, all electrons
with the same spin have
to be just a little bit
farther apart from each other.
So that minimizes the Coulomb
interaction just a little bit.
So actually, with
this correction,
the results seem to come and
match up with experiments
a lot closer.
And this is actually
the foundation
for molecular orbital theory.
So just by adding this spin
consideration into the Hartree
equation, we suddenly
have an equation that's
actually pretty functional.
So Jeff thinks this is
quite an emotional moment.
However, as I said, there
were two energy terms
that we were missing in that
original Hartree equation.
So we found the exchange
term, but we're still
missing the correlation term.
So there are some ways
to deal with this,
but I think the way we're
going to deal with this is just
by moving on to DFT.
So now, we're going to start
talking about DFT, which
I think is what you
guys are mostly using,
so you might find
this more interesting.
So the Schrodinger equation
is just really hard
to solve with all
of these electrons.
As we've said, it
takes a lot of time.
It takes a lot of
computational expense.
So let's divide space into the
worst grid you could imagine.
I guess the worst
would be one point,
but the worst grid you can
imagine is 2 by 2 by 2.
And let's think about
the number of points
that we need to keep track of
if we're calculating something
with little n electrons.
So if you only have one
electron, it's only eight,
and it's not too bad
to keep track of.
If we go up all the
way to 1,000 electrons,
suddenly we have this
huge number of points
that we have to keep track of.
And that's just inconceivable,
even with today's computers.
Why try to do
something this big?
That would take forever.
So it'd be really
nice if we could
think about some other
aspect of the system
that we could calculate,
instead of keeping
track of every single one of
those electrons separately.
And a term like that is density.
So if we consider
density instead,
suddenly, it's pretty
much the same scaling
no matter how many
electrons you have.
So the electron
density definitely
seems to be a lot more
manageable than dealing
with each electron separately.
And so at some point,
someone's, like, well,
wouldn't it be nice
if we could just
calculate with density instead
of with wave functions?
Because think about it--
these wave functions
don't mean anything anyway
until you've squared
them to get the density.
That's the only thing that
we can measure anyway.
Why don't we just
look at the density?
So what if I could come up
with a function of energy that
was dependent on the
density of electrons?
And Walter Kohn actually won
the Nobel Prize in Chemistry
in 1998 with somebody else
for coming up with this idea.
So as I said, one reason
that we want to go to DFT--
it scales so much better than
the quantum chemistry methods.
And we're going to have to spend
so much less time, especially
as the systems get larger.
So let's look at an example.
So if we have two
atoms of silicon,
DFT and the two sample
quantum chemistry
codes all take about
the same amount of time.
If we try to calculate
100 atoms of silicon,
suddenly DFT is 5 hours,
which might sound long.
But the Moller-Plesset
is a year,
and the coupled cluster
approach is 2,000 years.
I don't think
anybody's tested that,
but I wouldn't recommend it.
But suddenly, you can see why
if you want to do anything
more than just two atoms,
maybe DFT would be a good way
to go about it.
So this is a graph just showing,
again, that DFT scales better
than all the other approaches.
So again, the basic
tenet of DFT is
we've taken this
really complicated,
multi-electron wave
function, which we already
had trouble enough calculating
in the quantum chemistry
method.
I mean, we already
found problems
that if we tried
to simplify this
by making this a function
of each individual electron,
we suddenly lost all
the electron correlation
and exchange, which is
pretty crucial to getting
these calculations right.
And we know that the square
of this wave function
is the electron density anyway.
So let's just think
about the density.
So does anybody know what a
functional is, any math people?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHELE: Great.
Great.
So generally a function, you
input a number and output
a number.
A functional, you input a
function and output a number.
So this is called "density
functional theory,"
because we are writing a
functional of the function
density.
Density is a function.
At every point in space,
there is a particular value
of the density.
And so we would like
to be able to solve
this energy as a
function of the density
or I guess a functional
of the density.
So of course, we're going to
see all the familiar terms
showing up-- the
kinetic energy, the ion
potential, the
ion-electron interaction,
electron-electron interaction.
We're going to see all
the same terms showing up.
And we'll just have to deal
with them slightly differently.
So the way we actually
go about solving this
is we write some equation of
all of the different terms,
as far as we know
what they look like.
We write out the density in
terms of its wave functions,
and then do a
functional derivative
of one of these wave functions.
And so the functional
derivative works--
it's basically just a
variational principle.
Are you guys familiar with
the variational principle
in quantum mechanics?
The lowest energy possible for
a system is the ground state.
And so any time that you can
find any system that gives you
a lower energy, you're getting
closer to the ground state.
So I have my basic
Schrodinger equation.
If I can change something
about this wave function
such that when I solve this
equation I get a lower energy,
I probably have something that's
closer to the true ground state
than I used to have.
Because the smallest
possible value
for this energy that
I can get out of
this equation is going
to be the ground state.
So that's actually used a
lot in quantum mechanics.
So maybe I don't know exactly
what this function looks like,
but I can kind of guess what
this function looks like.
And I can minimize this energy
with respect to what exactly
this wave function looks like.
And that's exactly
what we're doing here.
We're minimizing this
energy the best that we can,
to try to get something that's
as close to the ground state
as we can.
So that leads to the
Kohn-Sham equations.
Again, this is pretty
much the same Hamiltonian
you've been looking at all
class, all last week, too.
We have the kinetic term.
We have the potential term, and
that acts on a wave function,
and gives us some eigenvalue
times the wave function.
So in this case, our
potential is broken up
into a couple of
different terms.
So we've already made the
Born-Oppenheimer approximation.
So we're ignoring the
ion-ion potential.
We can add that in whenever.
That doesn't change.
We have the ion interaction
with the electrons.
We have the electrons
interacting with themselves.
And now we have this new term
that's called the "exchange
correlation potential."
So this is the energy right
here that we were missing before
in the quantum
chemistry approach.
But there's a
problem-- we actually
don't know what this
exchange correlation
function looks like.
So people use a bunch of
different approximations.
The two most commonly used are
the local density approximation
and the general
gradient approximation.
And they're pretty
self-explanatory.
The local density
approximation, you just
approximate the local density
as being a flat in a local area.
And the general
gradient approximation,
you assume a first derivative.
So if you have some potential
that looks like this,
the local density approximation
might approximate it
as looking something like that,
whereas the general gradient
approximation would get
the slopes for each.
So generally, the general
gradient approximation
ends up being a little
bit more accurate,
but they both have their
strengths and weaknesses.
And depending on what
problem you want to solve,
you really need to pay
attention to what you
should expect from either one.
So how does this
process actually work?
So this is a lot like the
solution to the Hartree
equation.
We start with our guess at the
position of the ions, which
may or may not change.
From there, we
also need to start
with a couple initial parameters
that we didn't talk about
for the Hartree case.
So in this case, we're going
to pick a cut-off for the plane
wave basis.
So that's something I'm going
to talk about in a minute.
I haven't talked about that yet.
Then we guess what our electrons
look like in the system.
From that guess
of the electrons,
we calculate the terms in the
Hamiltonian that we're missing.
We solve the Hamiltonian.
We just diagonalize it.
And that diagonalization
gives us a new density.
And then again, we ask,
is this density close
enough to our input density
or is it pretty far away?
And if it's pretty far
away, we go back up,
use that new calculated density,
again to calculate the terms
in the Hamiltonian
that we were missing,
diagonalize the Hamiltonian
again, get a new density.
And we just keep doing this
again and again until we've
found something
that we say is close
enough to the original
density that we've probably
found something that's
a good approximation.
So you'll notice
that this is actually
different from the Hartree.
So this looks very similar to
the solution of the Hartree
equation, but you'll notice that
instead of solving one electron
wave function at
a time, every time
we have to do the
self-consistent cycle.
All we have to do here is just
diagonalize this Hamiltonian.
So this is why the
process speeds up so much.
There are a bunch of
software that people
use for DFT calculations.
Some of them are free.
Some of them are not.
I think you guys
are using Siesta,
which is not on this table.
But all of these
different software
have their strengths
and weaknesses.
And depending on what
you want to calculate,
you should probably
think about which
model is the best for you.
But we're going to be looking
at a PWscf input file,
just to give you a general
idea of what these input files
look like. and I guess pretty
soon you'll find out anyway,
since you'll have to
write some of them.
So I promised you I was going
to talk about basis functions.
That was that one parameter
in the self-consistent cycle
that you have to pick.
So a basis function is
basically just whatever function
you like, what function you want
to deal with mathematically,
that you can write your
wave functions in terms of.
So all we do is we take our wave
functions and we expand them.
So we get some linear
combination of whatever basis
we like.
So usually, people pick
Gaussians, or plane waves,
or things that are
really easy to calculate,
because you can write
any wave function
in terms of a linear
combination of these,
as long as you have
a complete basis.
So we pick these spaces such
that it's orthonormalized.
What we can do from
that is when you
multiply one of
these by another one,
you'll get a delta function.
So basically, if I
multiply through by--
so I have to integrate
over all space
because these functions
exist over all space.
So I integrate over all space.
I pick one of these
particular basic functions
that I multiply by.
And that picks out exactly
the j basis function here.
So this whole term,
when I integrate out,
because it's orthogonal, I
only get the j term here.
Because it's
normalized, I get 1.
So I'm just left with this
E and c j on this side.
On this side, when I do that
same integration over all space
and multiplication by
this j basis function,
I get something more
complicated because I have
this Hamiltonian in between.
So this Hamilton,
this H i j function,
is actually not quite
as simple as it looks.
It's an integration over all
space of the Hamiltonian acting
on the basis set i, and then
the inner product of that
with basis set j, the
complex conjugate.
But this is something
we can calculate.
This actually ends up
being the Hamiltonian
that we diagonalize in the end.
So you can see that the choice
of these basis functions,
to make it something that's
easy to calculate this term,
is going to be really crucial
for getting the shortest
possible computation time.
One that's commonly
used is plane waves.
This is a plane wave.
The exact form of the ones
we use, e to the i G j dot r.
You guys know the e to
the i x is equal to cosine
x plus i sine x.
So you can see why these
are called "plane waves,"
because in real space, they're
basically just some wave.
So this r is the
real space vector.
What we have to do
is pick what j's
we're going to use
in our simulation.
So really, if we're going to
expand any function in terms
of this basis, we need
the spaces to be complete,
which means basically
what it says.
It's "complete," meaning you can
expand anything in terms of it.
But we don't really want
a complete basis set,
because for this to
be complete, this G
would have to go to infinity.
We'd have to go for every number
for G between 0 and infinity,
and we don't have the
computational time to do that,
because the size of our
Hamiltonian that we diagonalize
depends on the number of these
functions that we put in.
So what we hope to do
is pick a maximum G
that's sufficient to capture
all of the physics that happens,
but not so big that our
computational time takes
forever.
So as I increase G, I
get shorter and shorter
wavelengths.
And at some point,
this wavelength
is going to be so
short that it's
going to represent a really
high kinetic energy system.
And it's going to
be just un-physical.
I mean, if I have an atom here,
an atom here, an atom here,
probably the variation
in the electron density
is not this great right
around that nucleus.
And so at some point,
we can just cut off G,
and say we have enough.
We can probably
capture all the physics
we need just going up
to the G that we have.
So you can see actually how this
plane wave basis works really
well for periodic crystals.
I just drew nuclei here.
So when you have an
infinite crystal,
you have a nucleus here, a
nucleus here, a nucleus here.
And because they're
all the same,
you don't expect that the
wave function or the density
should be different
at this nucleus
than it is at this nucleus.
So this plane wave is actually
a great representation of that
because the density is the
same here as it is here,
as it'll be here.
And so these plane
waves are actually
ideal for calculating
periodic crystals.
So how are we going
to attack molecules?
What we're going to do is
put these molecules in a box.
We're going to put them in a
box with some amount of vacuum
on either side, and then repeat
that box in all directions.
In x, in y, in z, we're going
to infinitely repeat this box.
And so now instead of having
an atom here, an atom here,
an atom here,
we're going to have
a molecule here, and a molecule
here, and a molecule here.
So you can see how
maybe with this,
these plane waves might
represent that system
a little bit better.
But there are some
things you have to take
into consideration with this.
Since there's a molecule here
and some distance away there's
another molecule, they might
interact with each other.
And if you want just the
properties of that molecule
by itself in vacuum, you
don't want them interacting
with other molecules.
So you need to make
sure that you've
included enough vacuum
between these molecules,
between the molecule and
the edge of its unit cell,
that the interaction
will be negligible
or will be on the
order of the error
that you have from everything
else in your calculation.
So once we've done
this, we can then
start our self-consistent loop.
So what happens?
We put in where the ions are.
We calculate our potential.
We've guessed at some
original electron density.
We've calculated all the
terms in the Hamiltonian.
We've diagonalized
that Hamiltonian.
That diagonalization
gives us our energy.
And then the program said, well,
that new density wasn't really
close to the old density.
So let's do that again.
And it does that again,
and calculates energy.
And you can see how the
energy always goes down.
So this is a negative number.
The energy always goes down.
So that's the
variational principle--
as you approach the
correct ground state,
you get lower in energy.
And you can see
that the difference
between these successively
gets smaller and smaller.
And that's what you really want
to have happen, because that
means that your
energy is converging,
and you'll end up with a
pretty good approximation
of the ground state energy.
You've also ended up
with the charge density,
because that's what you've been
calculating this whole time
to calculate the energy.
So just with those
two properties,
and being kind of
clever, you can actually
calculate a huge range of
important molecular and solid
properties.
So you calculate at least
you can guess at a structure.
You can calculate bulk
modulus, shear modulus,
elastic constants.
You can calculate vibrational
properties and sound velocity.
Binding energy is
actually just probably
going to be this energy
that you've calculated.
You can kind of guess
at reaction pathways.
Those are a little bit harder
to do with this approach.
You can calculate
forces, pressure, stress.
You can calculate all
of these properties just
with this simple calculation
that we can now do.
But how do we know that these
calculations are meaningful?
How do we know that we've
actually said anything useful?
Dirac was complaining
that he found
that his calculations never
really matched experiment,
but don't lose heart.
But when should you lose heart?
Or when should you
maybe check to make sure
that what you're doing is
as accurate as you can get?
We need to talk
about convergence.
So there are a couple
of different properties
that you need to worry about.
We talked about is
the basis big enough.
So that's, did I
pick a high enough G
that I got enough wiggliness
of my wave functions, my input
basis wave functions,
that I've captured
all the relevant physics?
And so this is the trade-off.
It takes more time if you
have a larger basis set,
but you also lose some
accuracy by decreasing
the size of your basis set.
And at some point,
when you've taken out
too many basic
functions, you suddenly
get something that's not
going to be meaningful
at all because you just don't
have the right structure
of the potential.
We talked about is
the box big enough.
Did you include enough
vacuum so that you
don't get interactions between
molecules in neighboring unit
cells?
Because if you want the
properties of the molecule
by itself in vacuum,
you don't want
the interaction of those two
molecules to play a part.
But here we get, actually, a
trade-off with the basis set.
So the bigger you make
your box, the bigger
you need your basis set to be.
So you can see if this is
the size of my box here,
and this is my cut-off--
G has a wavelength of this--
if I suddenly make
my box much bigger,
this wavelength
is going to expand
and it's going to be a
much bigger wavelength.
And so maybe now
this is actually
an important wavelength
to my system.
And maybe even a
smaller wavelength
is an important
wavelength to my system.
Does that make sense?
OK, so making your
box bigger means
that you need a bigger
basis set, which
means more computational
time, but on the other hand,
you don't want to include
the effects of intermolecular
interaction.
Finally, you can ask if you
exited the self-consistent loop
at the right time.
So I keep saying, well,
we compare the old density
to the new density and
if they're close enough,
then we assume it's right.
But what's that definition
of "close enough?"
And how do you know that that
definition of "close enough"
is close enough?
So that's another
property that you're going
to have to converge along.
So let's just take a look
at an example input file,
and see how some of these
properties that you need
to converge along, and the
other properties you might care
about, show up in this system.
So we might care about
putting in the right atoms,
talk about how the
atoms are related
to each other spatially,
and then these three
parameters that we talked about
that we need to converge along.
So this is just a
sample of water.
And so here, this is
the size of the cell.
This is the number of atoms,
number of types of atoms.
This is ecut, this
is the energy cutoff,
which refers to
the size of your G,
and then your atoms and
the atomic positions.
And these are just
the pseudo potentials.
So we haven't talked at all
about pseudo potentials,
but just so you know,
we talked about the fact
that when we think
about atoms we only care
about the valence electrons.
So all those core
electrons still exist,
but we don't want
to calculate them.
So we use pseudo potentials
to sort of capture
those inner electrons
a little bit,
and tell us how those
inner electrons are
going to affect the valence
electrons and everything else.
Because when we
have an atom that
has some core of electrons--
so let's say this
has 27 protons in it.
An electron out
here is not going
to feel that 27 proton charge.
It's going to feel that
27 protons shielded
by some number of
core electrons.
And so to get the Coulomb
interaction right there,
we need to have some
kind of modified version
of what exactly our atoms'
potential looks like.
So that's what the pseudo
potentials are about.
So that's it.
We've covered the basis of
quantum chemistry and density
functional theory today.
Are there any questions?
All right, thank you.